thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome to I'd like to know
this program is our Bible question and
answer program it gives us the Blessed
opportunity to answer your questions
from the word of God I'm in the company
of two distinguished gentlemen students
of the word to my left Pastor Stephen
Bohr president of Secrets unsuit and
some TV pastor always good to have you
here it's wonderful to work with you CA
thank you I I will accept the compliment
uh and to my right we can't really call
him new anymore because the the sunshine
is sort of worn off he's not new anymore
he's one of the one of the old friends
and old favorites here this is Pastor
David Salazar Pastor he is the general
manager of our some TV Latino Channel
doing a fine job and just a nice guy
great smile good looking guy good to
have him as part of the team thank you
Pastor it's a blessing for me to be with
you a gentlemen really learning from you
guys
praise the Lord again this is our
question and answer program we answer
the questions that you send in from the
Bible and we love doing so which makes
this one of our favorite programs here
at some TV should you want to be part of
this program and we we import tune you
we ask that you do that send in your
questions to TV TV at some
s-u-m-tv.org that's TV at some tv.org
we promise we will get to your questions
as soon as we can we are happy to say
that our questions are coming in from
all over the world that means that our
footprint is expanding that many are
watching and many are being blessed so
if you don't hear your question a day or
two after you send it in hold on we'll
get to it we are getting questions from
all over the world and we praise God for
that we promise you also that your
answers will come from the word of God
we are students of the word we we try to
bring everything from the word and we
don't want to interweave our own opinion
or our own thoughts into the program we
want to give you the word of God because
it is the word of God that will help you
grow in the things of the Lord so we
want to give you good spiritual food
from the word of God so Pastor Salazar
if you would ask the Lord's blessing
upon this particular program we'll
launch that with our first question let
us pray Heavenly Father we thank you
Lord this moment for the opportunity
that you give us to be able to come
together and to share from your word
we ask that you will send us the Holy
Spirit help us to receive that
Enlightenment that comes from you so
that our answers may come from your word
and may give Clarity and direction to
those who are asking we pray all these
in Jesus name amen amen amen and amen
now this question
um that comes to us from Ghana from the
country of Ghana uh from agbe de la uh I
hope I haven't butchered that up too
much Pastor Bohr thinks he off answered
this question many many eons ago when he
do this program by himself but we
realize we get new viewers all the time
and we're happy for that so our viewing
audience is growing so there may be
others who have this same question so
we're going to take a look at it again
it comes to us from First Timothy
chapter 4 verse 3 and
Pastor David do you have that that yes
if you would read that for us please yes
it reads the following forbidden to
marry and commanding to abstain from
Meats which God had created to be
received with Thanksgiving of them which
believe and know the truth
so the question I guess the the texting
question is that verse about
forbidding to marry and for almost
abstaining from Meats
all right
um
anybody want to launch out with that
well I suppose his questioning if this
is about the SDA Church some people say
that you know because we as a church
have principles of diet and certain
things we say we shouldn't eat that's
the only way that I suppose because the
church never forbids anybody to remain
married I mean we believe in the
marriage
between a woman and a man as God
institution is it to it but uh therefore
forbidding somebody to eat Meats
we only follow the principles of the
Bible that the Lord gives us in
Leviticus and you know even before then
actually with the in between the
distinction of of meats of clean and
unclean Meats
um that's what the other Church holds we
do have a recommendation as far as
becoming vegetarian but it doesn't mean
that you know we are saying that you
can't necessarily eat clean Meats but
perhaps the answer goes beyond that
Pastor what I think is that um
the key to this verse is that they will
teach to abstain from Meats the word
Meats is not a good translation it's the
word Brahma in Greek it refers to Foods
so
commanded to abstain from foods which
God has created to be received
so we need to ask what foods did God
make to be received that are going to be
forbidden
well Genesis 1 29 tells us what foods
God created yeah it says God said
I see I have given you every herb that
yields seed which is on the face of all
the Earth and every tree whose fruit
yields seed to you it shall be for food
right so what is one of the things that
God created to be partaken with
Thanksgiving they are the foods that God
uh you know that God speaks of in
Genesis chapter 1 and verse 29 right now
does this other thing they have at his
church forbid people to eat fruits and
vegetables I don't think so we encourage
them to eat fruits and vegetables right
so
um you know to say that this text is
speaking about Seventh-Day Adventists
neither neither do Seventh-Day
Adventists forbid to marry right we
encourage people to marry we celebrate
uh you know marriages very commonly in
The Seventh-Day Adventist Church so it's
a stretch to take this text and say oh
it applies to evidence because
Adventists forbid eating pork and
forbidding eating uh you know fish
without skins without scales and fins
and so on it's to totally take it out of
context I was playing an extra little
game with myself I wanted to hear what
you gentlemen had to say because I
remember years ago I had a program on
another Network an Evangelical Network
and I was unabashedly Adventist and I
would load it up with the Adventist
pastors as my guests and whatnot but
every now and again uh uh Evangelical
Pastor would be asked to come on a
program and one tried to sort of hang me
with this this text you know okay
um uh and so I wanted to hear your
answers because uh of the answer I gave
him at that time the Bible says now
expressly in the latter times some will
depart from the faith so this is not
addressed to Adventists these are people
who are who are taking the the faith and
twisting the faith and and manhandling
the faith so it's not dressed to Advent
it's because it's people who are outside
of the faith one we don't forbid to
marry there is a church a couple
actually that that forbid to marry and
then the rest of this text really leans
on where you place the the comma or the
the semicolon
um commanding to abstain from Meats
which God has created to be received
everything God hasn't created to be
received no you know there are some
things he created for other purposes you
know
um you know there are certain things
swimming in the ocean crawling in the
Seas when you build an aquarium and you
build a habitat you put snails in there
why do you put the snails in there
because the snails eat the fish
droppings they are cleaners there are
certain things that are put on the Earth
for garbage cans basically they're
they're there God put them there to keep
the earth clean right they they eat
carrion they eat dead things and if you
eat them you are de facto eating dead
stuff so God didn't put them there to be
received so there goes this cargo
I buy there it goes indeed they weren't
put here to be received with
Thanksgiving they were put here for a
purpose absolutely that purpose was not
to go into your mouth it was for
something else they're good for that
purpose but not for food you know it's
helpful to read uh verse 3 in other
versions of the Bible correct more
contemporary versions uh the NIV which
is uh one of the most uh common you
commonly used today uh it says they
forbid people to marry and order them to
abstain from certain foods which God
created God did not create pork to be
eaten amen right so that totally
disqualifies you absolutely so so when
and it continues saying
um you know in verse let's begin with
verse three again they forbid people to
marry and order them to abstain from
certain foods which God created to be
received with Thanksgiving by those who
believe and know the truth and then it
says for everything God created is good
so some people say see everything God
created is good we can eat anything but
the context indicates that everything
that God created to be partaken of is
good absolutely right according to the
context right it's not everything that
he made you know in that case uh you
know you could drink a gallon of uh a
gallon of antifreeze you know and you
could eat uh you could eat things that
are told you rats yeah cockroaches you
know because supposedly God created them
mushrooms you know I mean poisonous
mushrooms
so so you know people will take uh verse
4 for everything God created is good and
nothing is to be rejected
if it is received with Thanksgiving but
they they don't look at the previous
verse yes where the previous verse says
everything that God created to be eaten
is good and God did not create
everything like ca was saying to be
eaten to be eaten they have a function
right not to go in your stomach uh I had
a roommate in when I was at Oakwood uh
from Liberia they used to used to eat
kangaroo rats they would roast them and
you know put them on a little stick uh
kangaroo a little hopping little rat and
of course when he became a dentist it
was one of one of the hardest things for
him to give up was kangaroo rats we did
develop a taste for it I said would
would wouldn't be hard for me
but it was hard for him so God created
all of these things and of course some
things uh are are a result of sin but
not to be put in your mouth just to be
crass yeah it's kind of like putting a
pork chop on your plate and saying
please Lord bless this which thou Hast
cursed because there's a curse upon
eight important in chapter 65 of Isaiah
not only pork but rats
but but the Bible is very clear uh you
know and and some people say well but
God allowed clean Meats
there's no evidence that this is even
talking about Meats right because it's
food it's true that God created right
but they say you know
um you know God allowed clean Meats well
what God allowed in the past
is different than what he would allow
these days yes yes because with the
hormones that are injected in the
animals to make them grow faster with
the disease the proliferation of disease
and so on uh what used to be safe he's
no longer safe it's no longer safe so uh
can God change his counsel these days
through Ellen White and say listen that
which was safe in the past right isn't
safe anymore safe anymore and that's why
some people say well Ellen White says
you're not supposed to eat meat at all
and the Bible says we can eat meat well
because when circumstances change God
changes his concept and people that hate
the truth Pastor you know as you
mentioned will try to use
the light the Lord has given us for
today's experience about food or eating
healthier to say you know she's going
contrary to the Bible by by saying that
we couldn't eat or shouldn't eat certain
things but at the same time is really
the progressive light that the Lord has
allowed us to have where we are to
really go back to the original plan that
the Lord had which is the best for us
the Lord allowing the children of of
well the people of of God to eat certain
Meats was more of a consequence of sin
and of the condition that the world was
there after the flood but really there
was no indication that God from the very
beginning was creating lambs and and
animals to be eaten that was not the
purpose of God well we had the original
diet we we have it exactly and and of
course after after the flood things were
allowed but you know because it's
allowed doesn't mean and I think your
point is very important uh Pastor Bohr
things have deteriorated if you go into
a slaughterhouse or you go into you it
would make you the fastest vegetarian I
mean you know if you see what how
animals are handled and how the the meat
that's on your plate got there and look
at the the stream of of happiness is how
it got there that would turn you off so
fast yeah that would make you a de facto
vegetarian because you just who wants to
be bothered with that especially
especially when you go to like the Latin
American countries and you go to the
market and there's there's slabs of meat
hanging on a hook and you see the Flies
coming in City I'll tell you what it'll
make you vegetarian in a hurry you know
some of this thing you and you have to
you have to pray when you're reading the
Bible for for discernment and you cannot
read it blindly you know if you take
something and it seems to be saying this
investigators is it really saying that
and if I take this to his logical
conclusion does it make sense just
because I pray over something that's
deadly or poisonous or injurious it's
going to make it clean and make it
acceptable that that doesn't make sense
you're you're attempting the Holy Spirit
you're attempting the lord well here's a
piece of snake meat but I want that and
I'm going to eat that so Lord make it
clean bless it to Nursery bodies in
Jesus name amen now it's ready let's
let's go eat that that doesn't make
sense really when God has given you a a
list of things that are acceptable and
things that are not acceptable and you
can't change it just because you want to
eat it and you want to pray about it
some people twist the scriptures for
example you have the these uh churches
that pick up snakes poisonous snakes yes
because they use where Jesus said you'll
pick up a snake and he'll bite you and
it won't do anything to you now I've
never found a church where where they
say that whatever if you drink a poison
because it says there if you're drinking
poison you know it'll happen I've never
heard of any church where they where
they will drink uh poison directly you
know because that's uh that's pushing it
a little bit yeah it's pushing it a lot
so so but but my point is that people
will take verses of the Bible and they
will twist them
to their own destruction that's right is
what the Apostle Peter said about the
way some people were using the writings
of Paul right and the other scriptures
as well yes so we need to be we need to
come with an open mind amen with an open
heart we need to be sincere in our study
in the Bible and not go to the Bible
because we like this and so I'm going to
try and fi and justify it yeah what the
Bible says well said well said
we are not condemning you our comments
are not aimed at you because we've heard
these questions before I certainly have
I know you have and and you probably
have also uh Pastor Salazar so we're
we're answering the the idea or the
ethic that is behind this kind of
question because obviously somebody has
brought it to you well they've brought
it to us also we've heard it before
we've seen it before and we've seen the
heart that many times this comes from so
that's why we're answering it as we are
from the word of God and the word of God
is pretty plain about some of these
things and so we're just lifting up the
word of God and we thank you so much for
your question amen amen
all right this one comes to us from the
Solomon Islands out in the Pacific Ocean
welcome to the Solomon Islands that's a
fair ways away from here and this is
from Ricky
um dear sir I am confused when I listen
when I listen to one black preacher from
the from state from the states I guess
regarding the Sabbath day of worship
um his name is Willie's name out for now
uh because it doesn't really matter what
his name is we're going to tell the
truth and that supersedes all other
names he was trying to explain that
there are two sabbaths one is the Old
Testament Sabbath the other is the New
Testament Sabbath the Old Testament
Sabbath leads to Canaan the New
Testament Sabbath leads to New Jerusalem
and he goes on to say uh that he keeps
the Sabbath every day I've heard that
before yeah and he really discredited
the seven of us or keeping only one
Sabbath which he said Sabbath at Moses
times in the Old Testament time is
finished can you explain what he is
trying to preach here yes we can and we
would love to
we don't have enough time so we have to
try to compact this in
first of all and I'll I'll take I'll
fire one bullet and then we'll let you
guys uh get a shot too please the
Sabbath existed long before Moses and
any Seventh-Day Adventists amen and amen
Sabbath was created at creation so it is
not Mosaic nor is it Adventist it's
God's Sabbath and the Bible speaks of it
as God Sabbath and it was a memorial of
creation long before Abraham the quote
First
Jew
um the Sabbath was in existence so I'll
put a period there for now and then let
you guys take a shot
well I think the Bible is absolutely
clear
um at creation to pick up where you were
left off
uh in Genesis chapter 2
and verse 2 it says and on the seventh
day amen that's one not all yes on the
seventh day God ended his work which he
had made and had done and he rested on
the
seventh day from all his work which he
had done then God blessed the seventh
day I think God is trying to give us the
impression that the seventh day is the
day we're supposed to rest we're
supposed to keep and then of course we
have Exodus chapter 20.
the Bible is clear on this point by the
way
there's there's no reason to try and
find a way around it uh Exodus chapter
20 sends us back to Creation
remember the Sabbath day to keep it holy
six days you shall labor into all your
work but the seventh day is the Sabbath
of the lord lord your God in it you
shall do no work you nor your son nor
your daughter nor your male servant nor
your female servant nor your cattle nor
your stranger who is within your Gates
now comes the reason it the reason is
going back to Creation which shows that
the Sabbath is a creation Institution
for in six days the Lord made the
heavens and the Earth the sea and all
that is in them and rest of the seventh
day therefore the Lord blessed the
Sabbath they inhaled it I mean the Bible
is so clear that you wonder why somebody
would stand up uh a spiritual leader and
say only and I keep the Sabbath every
day the Bible does not say that anywhere
absolutely one you don't have to keep
the Sabbath every day and if you kept
the Sabbath every day you would be uh
defrauding the Lord uh who tells you you
need to take care of your family need to
work and support yourself because if
you're keeping the Sabbath as the Bible
designs it should be kept you're not
working you're not doing anything
secular uh you're worshiping seven days
a week all the time every day 24 hours a
day it cannot be done you cannot sing
your family or provide for those that
are around you you know you have to do
part of the blessing that the lord gave
men after sin was to work I mean it was
a curse but a blessing in disguise kept
occupied kept in mind uh BC gave a
purpose for a man so if you start
thinking of prayer you know your life
for seven days a week or standing you
know reading and reading and reading
even though that's good is not a
balanced it's not a balanced experience
and and God set apart the seven day
Sabbath for a purpose to remind us first
of all he's the Creator to allow us to
connect with him to worshiping him to to
change our routine from the regular type
of work that we do and to come to him
and spend time in study in Fellowship
when another and making it also a very
special day more so than the end of the
week now it doesn't make sense for for
me to to hear these guys saying that he
keeps this every day because as you
mentioned Pastor he would have to be
preaching or or praying to God all the
time and at the same time uh what would
you know what does it mean keeping the
Sabbath really for what for this man I
mean is it is it that he doesn't keep
the the law of the god or or or or or
those that are not following the I don't
know his his com his leadership or his
ideas I I believe that he has a
confusion this man about what it means
to keep the Sabbath as you mentioned I
don't think he understands at all what
it means to give this other I I'd be
curious to find out
which Bible verses this teacher is using
I would ask him okay very interesting
what you're saying
where do you find it in the Bible yeah
yeah yeah and there's no words in the
Bible and you know what gentlemen part
of the Commandment says six days shout
thou labor and do all thy work so if you
are working on the seventh day you're
breaking the Commandment but if you're
not working on the other six days you're
also breaking the command that's right
precisely get out of your bed and work
so if you're keeping the Sabbath every
day you are breaking the Commandment one
two
The Ten Commandments are a linked chain
James tells me if I break one I break
them all right so if if the Sabbath
which is at the heart of The
Commandments the longest of them all is
done away with what about
honoring your parents what about number
seven adultery what about you know so if
if if if the Commandment that says keep
the Sabbath has done away with then the
the whole tanglements have to be done
away with so then you don't have any
anchor you have no Direction you're not
the The Stance of this this preacher is
untenable it's it's biblical absolutely
and it shows really and I'm not
beating up on this guy but it shows a
lack of understanding of how God works
and how God functions and his his stated
commands in in the word of God now he
would you know it's interesting a lot of
you know first day preachers that have a
problem with the Sabbath
they have a problem only with that
commandment yes they no no one preaches
go ahead and kill go ahead and commit
adultery go ahead and lie and steal
whatever because you know it doesn't
make any sense you know God would never
allow such a behavior but somehow they
all have this enmity this anger against
this Heaven they Sabbath and the rest of
the Commandments are okay to keep except
that one it doesn't really make sense
specifically when we see that throughout
the whole Bible and we go to revelation
22 verse 14 it says blessed are they
that do his Commandments that they may
have their right to the tree of life so
is he
or anybody like this and this preacher
saying that God is telling you to keep
only nine Commandments not the ten not
the fourth somehow doesn't make any
sense God makes and he is as Christ
mentioned you know through in his own
words you know he came to fulfill the
law and not not even an adult you know a
small thing of of the love will be taken
away so I believe that we have to just
help these people understand or just
pray for this man that he may receive
the light that he's in error you know
the fact is
that all throughout history Satan has
shown his hatred for the Sabbath yes
you know he he showed his hatred for the
Sabbath by Leading the Jewish nation in
the first part of its history to trample
on the Sabbath which led to the
Captivity
after
he led people to idolize the Sabbath
to distort the Sabbath the scribes and
the Pharisees early in the history of
the Christian church he led certain
leaders in the church to slowly
transition from Sabbath to Sunday
correct in the days of Constantine now
Sunday is replacing the Sabbath during
the 1260 years the little horn thinks
that it can change God's law the Sabbath
and in the end time the controversies
over the Sabbath it must be that the
Sabbath is extremely important yes or
else the devil would not hate it so much
why does he hate the Sabbath because the
Sabbath points toward the Creator his
rival Jesus because everything started
in heaven right with the enmity of Satan
against Christ Revelation 12 17 very
well known verse the dragon was enraged
with the woman yes that's right and he
went to make war with the remnant of her
seed and now we have the reason he hates
the remnant they they keep the
Commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ Satan hates
the Commandments particularly the
Sabbath and he hates the spirit of
Prophecy because the spirit of Prophecy
shows the in other words shows uh
how the Sabbath is going to be attacked
in the end time and how the Sabbath will
play a role in the final Conflict well
said well said think gentlemen what it
would be like
if everybody kept the Sabbath if the
world shut down one day a week and turn
their hearts toward the lord
and Satan knows that that this world
will not be the same if we all kept the
Sabbath together
um
the the thought just sort of makes your
head swim what kind of a Wonderful World
this would be so I hope we've really
done Justice to your question it's a
good question it comes back again and
again and again and of course we love
defending this Central tenet of our
faith again our time has fast lift into
eternity allow me in closing to wish you
both Grace and peace through our Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ we'll see you
again soon bye bye and God bless
foreign
[Music]